that stunning development in the war in
ukraine the flagship vessel of russia's
naval fleet off the southern coast of
the country has sunk after being hit by
ukrainian missiles according to ukraine
president zelinski says ukrainians
should be proud of having survived 50
days now under russian attack chris
livesay is in ukraine for us again this
morning chris good morning to you
good morning tony it was the powerhouse
of the russian navy in the black sea but
this morning well it's sitting at the
bottom of it along with the kremlin's
pride now russia is threatening to
increase attacks here in the capital
keeve
the warship moskva was designed in the
cold war to take out u.s aircraft
carriers instead it was taken out by
ukrainian-made neptune missiles ukraine
says the pentagon cannot confirm the
claim but we are also not in a position
to refute that
that it could have been a ukrainian
missile
which struck the ship
a ship that along with the russian navy
had been terrorizing ukraine's coastline
for years while moscow blames the
catastrophe on an unexplained fire it
admits the symbol of russian might has
sunk and has pulled back the rest of its
fleet this as russia continues to pull
back its ground forces after failing to
capture keeve leaving behind blood
stained boot prints in its wake tony
decouple spoke to ukraine's prosecutor
general investigating russian atrocities
you say 6 000 cases of war crimes how
many potential perpetrators have you
been able to identify
i think it will be actually thousands of
them and we understand that it will be
uh absolutely different uh level of
peoples it could be soldiers it could be
commanders it could be top level of
politicians and militaries the scale of
wholes ukrainian lawmaker alexi
honchorenko has come to the village of
havronshina to see for himself a family
of five allegedly gunned down as they
tried to flee the youngest only two
years old a stroller for a baby
oh my god look at that
and this baby was killed
yeah
i have son my own son is three years old
it's so hard yuri patsan is a local
farmer you live right there he says he
witnessed a russian armored vehicle open
fire with high caliber explosive rounds
even though the car bore a sign in the
back window that read children yuri says
he tried to save them but they died in
his arms
all he could do was bury them we're not
dogs like the russian soldiers he says
once the russians left he and the
ukrainian police exhumed the bodies for
investigation from what you know from
what you've seen does this constitute a
war crime
yes it's definitely war crime because
without any reason
civilians were killed the world should
know that it is not fake the world
should know
who is russian regime who is putin
that lawmaker told me bringing those
responsible to justice will be no easy
task he recalled that some nazi war
criminals were in their 90s when they
were finally captured ukraine will be
just as patient because they owe it to
the victims vlad
and the world will know because if
you're reporting chris livesay in
ukraine thank you very much